The world is a dangerous place but, depending
on where you’re from, tha dangers you face
can be very different.
Obviously a kid from war-torn Iraq is going
to be wary of completely different things
to a child from the wilds of Canada; bombs
versus bears, glaring sun versus metres of
snow.
So, please fasten your seatbelt, put on your
hard hat, sit down and take your tablets and
let’s look at just a few of the ways that
the world is trying to kill you.
With all the talk of driverless cars and Uber,
as well as ingenious safety systems like automatic
breaking, it’s easy to forget that driving
can actually be a pretty dangerous activity.
So what is the worst place to hop behind the
wheel?
Right now, it’s Iran, with a rate of about
44 per 100,000 people dying each year on the
roads.
That’s almost 15 times the rate in the UK,
which is the third safest place to drive in
the world, only beaten by Sweden and Micronesia.
However, countries like Libya and Iraq are
also high on the list of the most dangerous
places to drive, which is understandable since
the instability in those regions means there
is no real policing of the roads.
Also, the condition of the tarmac is probably
pretty awful.
War has an annoying tendency to make a big
mess of everything.
But there is no war in Iran, so what is the
reason behind their dangerous driving?
One main factor is actually the country’s
most popular car; the Kia Pride, made by Saipa.
It accounts for 40% of cars on the road and
is described by police as a “death coach”
and they’ve even asked for its production
to be halted.
The government has also waded in and one official,
Mohammad Reza Mamdouhi, described it as being
“detrimental to the mental health of those
who are easily agitated”.
As slogans go, I’ve heard better.
BMW - The Ultimate Driving Machine
Jaguar – Born to Perform
The Kia Pride – Putting the mental in detrimental
To be fair, it’s not quite as bad as the
old Volkswagen advert – Relieves Gas Pain.
Even Iran’s neighbours are scared of The
Pride.
Photos of a few dozen new models lined up
at the border prompted one Iraqi journalist
to joke that the question for Iraqis was “whether
the Pride is more dangerous than Daesh (ISIS)”
You might be thinking; if it’s so awful,
why does everyone drive it?
Well that’s largely down to the international
sanctions that have been put on Iran over
its nuclear weapons programme.
They don’t get a lot of foreign imports.
So the new nuclear treaty that has been signed
recently will hopefully open up the trade
of vehicles, much to the relief of the locals.
I’m pretty sure some of them would have
rather braved nuclear winter, than get in
the ironically named Pride once again.
For those people trying to go on a trip without
a car, there is always the chemical option.
The world takes a lot of drugs.
To give you some idea, so far this year, the
world has spent $120 billion dollars on illegal
substances, and it’s only April.
What’s more, that doesn’t include the
other billions from prescription drugs, which
are abused constantly.
The most drug related deaths per capita are
found in Iceland, which may surprise you,
at a rate of about 21 people per 100,000.
A lot of the other northern European countries
are high on the list too, Finland and Estonia
for example.
We suspect those long winters, with month
after month of darkness, can really take a
toll on your mood so it makes sense you might
want a bit of escapism.
Iceland also has the highest percentage of
marijuana users, with almost 20% of the population
estimated to take it regularly.
Scotland leads the world for cocaine usage,
at 2.5% of the population, which is maybe
why tourists have such a hard time understanding
what they’re saying.
And, surprisingly, Australia is the world’s
leading user of ecstasy, with about 3% of
the country taking it.
You would have thought permanent sunshine
and beaches would be enough, but apparently
not.
In the US, which is very high on the list
of drug related death nations, the notorious
War on Drugs is generally believed to have
failed.
John Ehrlichman, one of Richard Nixon’s
lead advisors, has admitted that the Comprehensive
Drug Abuse Prevention and Control Act of 1971,
that was the real start of the war on drugs,
was really a policy tool to go after anti-war
protesters and black communities, since they
were the biggest political threat to Nixon
at the time.
Drug legalisation is beginning to appear around
the world, now that governments can look at
the data provided by pioneering programs in
countries such as the Netherlands, Portugal
and Mexico.
Cannabis legalisation in the states seems
to be going smoothly and cannabis legal states
had massive revenues of $5.4 billion in 2015,
and they’re thought to rise again to $6.7
billion this year.
Colorado alone generates over $10 million
in tax a month for its state government.
That’s the power of going green.
But, overdose is not the only way drugs can
damage a country.
If you want to see some of its secondary effects
then we need to look at a different death
rate.
The Central American country El Salvador is
the murder capital of the world, having overtaken
Honduras in 2015.
Almost 1 in every 1000 people are killed every
year in El Salvador.
2015 was such a bad year that it’s believed
one person was killed per hour.
That makes El Salvador 20 times deadlier than
the US and 90 times deadlier than the UK.
Drugs play a big role since this is what provides
an income for the viscous gangs that terrorise
the country.
Some drugs, mainly cocaine, pass through from
South America on their way up to Mexico and
the US.
The drugs that are sold in El Salvador are
the cheaper form, crack cocaine.
It also has the world’s highest amphetamine
usage per capita.
El Salvador had a brutal 12 year civil war
from 1980 to 1992 and it left the country
in tatters.
Since that time, two main gangs began to establish
themselves.
Mara Salvatrucha (MS-13) and Barrio 18; both
gangs actually started out in Los Angeles,
MS-13 in the 80s and Barrio 18 as early as
the 60s.
But they both spread down into Central America
and are now the 2 most powerful groups in
El Salvador.
They are both highly organised and have very
strict codes of conduct for their members.
They often have full body and face tattoos,
with the numbers 13 and 18 featuring heavily,
depending on which side they’re on.
And like the hazard sign on a bottle of poison,
those marking are a very real warning, they
are brutal.
In August of 2015 the government tried to
enforce yet another crack down on the gangs
and they responded by executing a dozen bus
drivers, just to turn the city into chaos.
The whole month was a blood bath, with over
900 murders, 52 on just one day.
Surprisingly, the country still gets almost
1.5 million tourists a year.
A good deal is a good deal, I guess, just
remember to learn your gang greetings, you
never know when they might come in handy,
no pun intended.
Okay, now if we forget about human killers
for a moment, where do you think you are most
likely to be slain by one of our animal kin?
Let me try and read your mind…I bet most
of you are thinking…
Australia?
Right?
Well, I see why you would think that.
It seems like everything is out to get you;
spiders in your shoes, snakes in your car,
sharks under your surfboard, crocodiles in
your pool, ostriches and kangaroos just generally
hanging about, looking menacing.
But, although these dangers are real, the
actual death rate is surprisingly low.
This is probably due to good access to medical
care and a general awareness of how to deal
with these creatures.
Finding the deadliest animal country is actually
pretty tricky but it looks like it could be
Nigeria.
I’d better point out that we have discounted
mosquitos and tsetse flies as killers here,
since although they do spread a huge amount
of deadly disease; they themselves are not
the actual killers.
So that leaves us with our next most lethal
group; snakes.
Part of the problem is that in many countries,
people don’t head to hospital after being
bitten, choosing local healers instead, so
no data is collected.
In Nigeria, under 10% of bitees, not sure
if that’s a word… go to hospital, possibly
accounting for its very high death rate from
snake bites of 14 people per 100,000.
To make matters worse, Nigeria has a shortage
of antivenom thanks to distribution issues,
costs, and a lack of good education in rural
areas.
The anitvenoms are pretty effective, reducing
the mortality rate by 70-90%, so the government
are working on improving access across the
country.
If you escape the snake, there’s a long
line of other creatures waiting to step up.
And the largest is the water horse, or Hippopotamus.
Hippos take out almost 3,000 people a year
globally, being very aggressive and highly
territorial.
At least in Africa, people are aware of the
dangers, but they are part of a very peculiar
story in South America.
The notorious Columbian drug dealer, Pablo
Escobar, imported a wide range of animals
for his zoo, which he made free to the public.
But when his empire crumbled, the animals
were turned loose and hippos have thrived
in their new environment, maturing much earlier
than their African counterparts.
The locals still see them as cute and friendly
but it’s all fun and games until one of
them bites your face off.
A final word on biting.
For any of you worried about shark attack,
here’s a reassuring thought, you’re statistically
much more likely to get bitten by Luis Suarez
than a shark.
Now we turn to matters of the heart.
But put down the flowers, and definitely throw
away those fatty chocolates, because we’re
talking about cardiovascular disease.
This is by far the world’s biggest killer,
with over 1 in 10 deaths being down to a bad
ticker.
And who leads the world as the land of the
broken hearted?
It’s the ex-soviet nation of Turkmenistan.
The country sits on top of Iran, like a cat
wrapped around its shoulders, but where Iran
has a reasonable healthcare system, Turkmenistan
is down in the bottom 20% of the world, according
to a World Health Organisation report from
2000.
So, it’s more of a Garfield than a Puss
in Boots.
Poor diet is another contributing factor.
The Turkmen diet consists of dishes such as
Plov, a dish made with rice and often the
very fatty mutton.
Then there are skewers of meats like mutton
and pork, called Shashlyk, as well as dumplings
called Manti.
And to quench their thirst?
Then you want to grab a delicious glass of
Chal, a sour white sparkling beverage, made
from fermented camel milk.
Mmm, I think I’d rather have a heart attack.
So, do what you’re told, and eat up all
your vegetables, or you’ll get sent to your
room, which isn’t exactly the worst punishment
in the world.
One punishment that is thankfully disappearing,
although rather slowly, is the Death Penalty.
Right now, 94 countries have a legal death
penalty, but only 37 actively execute people.
Of these 37, two are in the Americas, 11 in
Africa, 23 in Asia, and only Belarus in Europe.
In most cases, the punishment is reserved
for violent crimes, terrorism, and drug trafficking.
But in a few select countries the penalty
also sadly applies for adultery, apostasy
(meaning to abandon your religion) and homosexuality.
It’s not common but there have been executions
for all of these within the last 5 years.
Come on world, we’re better than that, aren’t
we?
Equatorial Guinea is currently the world leader
per capita, with 11.56 people executed per
million, leading 3.70 per million in Iran,
in second place.
But it is definitely China who has the itchiest
trigger finger since their total each year
easily matches that of the rest of the world
combined.
In the early 2000s, the number was up around
12,000 people a year but it has now come down
to around 2000.
The difference in attitude to capital punishment
is not a new thing.
The first country to remove it from their
law was Venezuela, all the way back in 1863.
Since 1989, at least one country per year
has moved to abolish it, with Fiji and Suriname
being the last two, in 2015.
When it comes to last meals, a study in the
US showed that fried chicken was probably
the most common request.
One man, Philip Workman, asked that his last
meal be a vegetarian pizza but rather than
giving it to him, they should give it to a
homeless person.
The prison declined his request but across
Tennessee, thousands of dollars of pizza were
donated to shelters on his behalf by good-willed
individuals.
Next up, well … more down actually, is falling.
It may be surprising to hear that falling
is the second most lethal accident after vehicle
collisions and, one study has claimed, that
it accounts for a whopping 35% of all accident
and emergency visits.
Your average emergency doctor’s day is probably
a couple of heart attacks, a stroke, a kid
who swallowed pen lid and then someone who
fell off a roof, horse, ladder, climbing frame
or palm tree.
If it’s the last one then it’s probably
Keith Richards, you don’t need to treat
him, he’s clearly invincible.
So who leads the way?
Well in the red corner, soon to be the black
and blue corner probably, we have the Titan
of Tumbles, the Prince of Plummeting…it’s
Zambia!
It’s very difficult to get exact data on
this but it seems like the southern African
nation is the falling capital, with a death
rate of 46 per 100,000.
There’s a combination of factors here that
could be the reason behind this.
Obviously, a lack of great medical facilities
will always increase the mortality rate, as
we’ve seen with many of the other examples
today.
But maybe there is something about the geography
of Zambia that adds to it.
It’s mostly a high plateau and there are
a series of hills, such as the Mafinga Hills
that are difficult to cross by car so you’ll
get more people climbing on foot through difficult
terrain.
It’s also home to one of the seven natural
wonders of the world; Victoria Falls.
And fall you will, on occasion, if you are
one of the few brave tourists to take a dip
in the world’s most dangerous pool.
Devil’s pool is a natural dell in the rock
that occurs right on the very lip of the tumbling
water.
Around August to January, the flow of the
river is quiet enough so that the natural
rock edge of the pool will keep you from being
hurled over the waterfall.
But, accidents have been known to happen so
obey the rules of the pool; that’s no bombing,
no running and no heavy petting.
Strangely, as dangerous as it looks, you’re
more likely to be one of the many people who
die each year, falling out of bed – around
500 annually in the US alone.
Turns out that falling dream is pretty
We turn now to a very small country in the
Himalayan Mountains, with a population of
just over 700,000.
It is the beautiful kingdom of Bhutan.
It’s not easy to visit, they strictly control
tourist numbers and there is a daily fee of
$250 that you have to pay, although it includes
your trips and hotel.
So what is the killer here, I bet you are
wondering; exhaustion from all the climbing?
Some kind of goat attack?
The answer is actually…
poisoning.
At 36 per 100,000, it is some way ahead of
the rest of the world, since everyone else
except New Guinea is under 10 per 100,000.
Due to a lack of regulation, Bhutan has allowed
a high quantity of heavy metals, such as chromium
and manganese, to simply be flushed into the
local water supply after experiments and so
on.
This is especially odd as the country is famous
for being one of the world’s leading environmentally
focused places.
I guess they never thought of it as a problem,
whereas in many industrial nations, there
is a long history of poisonings to look back
at.
Chromium, for example, was famously what contaminated
the town of Hinkley, California, and caused
noticeably higher rates of cancer, covered
in the Julia Roberts film Erin Brockovich.
More recently, the lead poisonings in Flint,
Michigan, show that we never know when the
water might go bad.
It was actually a lead poisoning that put
Bhutan in the news a few years back.
A man in Switzerland was diagnosed with heavy
metal poisoning and they found that on his
frequent trips to Bhutan, he had been taking
an alternative medicine and the pills were
covered in a red paint, high in lead.
The man was hoping to cure his condition of
Bell’s palsy, a type of face paralysis.
He was told the pills contained the hair of
a dead Bhutanese priest but when they were
analysed, no trace was found.
I personally, prefer my medicine without a
dead man’s fringe in it, but each to their
own, I guess.
And finally, one of the most First World Problems
I’ve ever come across.
The USA leads the planet for a truly heroic
way to go.
Averaging two embarrassing funerals per year,
it’s the country where you are most likely
to be crushed to death by a vending machine.
At least there’ll be plenty of snacks at
the wake.
So, the world might be a dangerous place sometimes
but let’s not all get too paranoid.
Life expectancy keeps on creeping up and you’ll
probably end up living far longer than you
wanted to anyway.
You might still be around for series 49 of
Games of Thrones.
For those of you that have managed to stay
alive all the way through this video, well
done and thanks for the view, subscribe for
more Thoughty2.